[Intro music]
ANNOUNCER:
THIS is Capitol TV.
[Music]
JUSTINE:
Greetings citizens of Panem and welcome to District 6
My name is Justine Ezarik and I’m a district
liaison to the Capitol.
As a part of the transportation hub for our
nation, we build everything from hovercrafts
– to high speed trains – to tactical vehicles
for our noble Peacekeepers.
Today, I have the privilege of showing you
the capabilities
of one of these high-powered machines.
To tell us more, I’m joined by Master Engineer,
Garrick.
GARRICK:
Thank you. It’s an honor to serve the Capitol.
The SJ7 Peacekeeper Assault Transport is
a state-of-the-art military vehicle
capable of deploying assets to any hostile
environment.
JUSTINE:
Well it’s certainly impressive. Tell us more.
GARRICK:
The SJ7’s advanced suspension can handle
any terrain with ease.
The powertrain outputs 827 brake horsepower
from a liquid-cooled Grantham 12 engine.
The windows are equipped with 70 millimeter
bulletproof glass.
The armor can withstand high caliber small
arms fire, shrapnel, and explosives up to
a K5 rating. [Explosions in background]
The V-hull design protects passengers even
if a detonation occurs
directly beneath the vehicle.
But I suggest we climb aboard, and experience
the vehicle firsthand.
[Engine noise, dramatic music]
[Door closes, Peacekeepers pat on door]
[Sounds of engine, dramatic music]
JUSTINE:
Thank you for your attention, citizens.
We hope you’ve enjoyed watching one of the
many ways District 6 great
contributes to our nation.
Love your labor, take pride in your task.
Our future is in your hands.
And don’t forget to register for updates
from Capitol TV...it’s mandatory.